a new bill making its way through the
legislature could make some big changes
in our state education system thank you
for joining us at 11 I'm Brian Loftus
and I'm Denise Valdez so assembly Bill
400 which is backed by Governor Lombardo
would bring 2 billion dollars to our
Nevada schools and also shake things up
at the Clark County School District
Sasha Loftus joins us tonight to break
it all down well Denise and Brian a lot
of people stood up in Carson City and
here in Las Vegas to back this bill
today making it as it makes its way
through the Nevada legislature it would
funnel a lot of money into our state
education system and revise some current
procedures in place
beg me to please support our families
and support AB 400 a push for Education
funding this bill ensures that every
child has access to the best education
possible AB 400 also known as Governor
Lombardo's education achievement
opportunity and accountability Act was
discussed at the Nevada legislature
Wednesday with this investment comes a
heightened level of expectation for
Nevada students an unprecedented
accountability for Nevada school
districts and their leadership The
Proposal includes 2 billion dollars in
new K-12 funding it is about giving
families the ability to be the drivers
in the education of their children and
provide scholarship funding for families
under the federal poverty threshold
another component making sure funded
programs provide results while
reinstating a past requirement to hold
back students who can't read by third
grade we will never see Improvement in
student outcomes without dedicating more
time to student instruction also an
effort to address teacher vacancies
something many say is needed and as a
member of the Hispanic community
I have seen firsthand how my community
suffers as thousands across the state
and our community work tirelessly to
help every child succeed
as of now the bill has just been
introduced and discussed in hearings it
has not yet been voted on a few members
of the State Assembly did question the
third grade retention requirement which
was originally removed in 2019 by a
democrat-backed bill Denise